- So the office will start
streaming on Peacock in January.
That's amazing.
So looking back on it,
do you have a favorite episode
or moment from the show?
'Cause I've asked this actually
a couple cast members of
yours and they have different ones.
- I have so many, I
think when Michael Scott,
played by the great Steve Carell.
is laying down on that table and,
and they're ripping the chest hair.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's not, that's the wrong one.
- That's not the office?
- Nope, nope.
- That's the same, that's
the guy from the office.
It's the guy from the office.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
No, there's too many
great scenes to mention.
I mean, there's too many.
There's too much.
But Dwight's beet form
as a bed and breakfast
was probably right up there for me.
- I'm gonna say, your
comedic timing is hysterical.
I think that dry humor is just so funny.
And y'all's chemistry
as a cast is amazing.
That's rare to find that.
So do people still send
you Dwight Schrute gifts?
Do they still do that?
- Oh yeah.
I get Dwight Schrute gifts all the time.
In fact I have, a lot
of this art back here-
- I like that bear.
- Hand drawn fan art, you know,
that people have given me.
But the best piece of
Dwight art I ever got,
and I don't know why I
never took a picture of it.
Someone took a beet and carved
Dwight's face in the beet
and it was so beautiful.
They had probably spent
like 37 hours doing it.
It was an incredible work of art
and I took it home and I put
it in the bottom of a bag,
and of course it was moldy and
rotted by the time I got home
and it was, it was like one of
those beautiful works of art
that just came and went.
It was like a snowflake.
- You had to enjoy it in the moment.
- Yeah.